as Democrats burned down their 2020
presidential frontrunner they give
President Trump a major fundraising
advantage and they scare away
independent voters according to a new
poll a serious question arises are
Democrats trying to lose this thing we
will examine why the left can't get
anything right then an Obama appointed
federal judge rules that Asians are not
being discriminated against at Harvard
she rules that they just have terrible
personalities we will take a look at
that case if it's heading up to the
Supreme Court and finally the Washington
Post of course gives us the dumbest
article on the Internet today all that
and more on Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Democrats are doing everything wrong now
this sounds like it could be just the
logline of my show you it sounds like
this could just be the general statement
but I'm not saying they're doing
everything wrong morally or they're
doing everything wrong as a matter of
policy I'm saying politically speaking
they're doing everything wrong it's not
as though President Trump is a
completely bulletproof candidate in 2020
he has vulnerabilities he's trying to
address those right now but he does have
weaknesses
the trouble is here for the Democrats
they just can't win for losing
they've got three major problems that
are only getting worse for them by the
day the first one is they are destroying
their presidential frontrunner so Joe
Biden is at the top of the pack for now
I don't know by the time you listen to
this tomorrow or the next day after we
record that might not be the case
anymore he has really got slim margins
now but he consistently polls the
highest against President Trump in the
general election part of this is he's
the only candidate who's a top-tier
candidate who has black support part of
this is he's one of the few candidates
that people don't think is a complete
crazy leftist even though he's willing
to pander to the left as much as he
wants because he doesn't really believe
anything but he's still the top-tier
candidate for them right now and the
Democrats are burning him to the ground
now while they burned him to the ground
they're using a specific instrument to
burn him to the ground which is
impeachment and specifically talking
about his business dealings in the
Ukraine and his son's business dealings
in the Ukraine while they do that while
they are burning him to the ground with
impeachment they're giving President
Trump a major fundraising advantage and
as they're doing all of this
they are scaring independent voters mad
so there's a new poll out from Monmouth
University shows that a plurality of
voters believe that Joe Biden pressured
Ukraine to stop investigating his son
this is the first poll and I think the
only poll to my knowledge that asked
this question they said do you think
that Joe Biden used the federal
government to pressure or the government
of the Ukraine to stop looking into his
son's crooked affairs 42% of respondents
said he probably did that 37% said he
probably did not do that 22% don't know
regardless of what happened and I know
we've been covering some of the fat
facts of that case for a week or so now
regardless of whether or not it happened
the worst news for Biden is that the
plurality of people think it happened
more people think it happened then think
it did not happen and this is not just a
party line vote it's not just 42% of
Americans like Trump so they just
believe him when he says that Joe Biden
was crooked in in Ukraine it doesn't
break down that way actually if you look
further into the poll 16 percent of
Republicans don't think that Joe Biden
did anything wrong in Ukraine pretty
interesting number even more interesting
than that is that 19 percent of
Democrats do believe that Joe Biden
engaged in some crooked behavior in
Ukraine
so people are paying attention to this
issue when the issue first came up on TV
I said anyway Biden plays this he's
gonna lose unless he just brushes it off
and tries to ignore it and tamp it down
he's gonna lose because just the fact
that it's in the news is gonna hurt his
poll numbers it already is so the
Democrats are burning down their top
tier candidate and they're doing it in
an effort to impeach Trump don't forget
if they hadn't tried if they weren't
currently trying to impeach Trump the
Ukraine issue would not exist
this Ukraine issue goes back to 2014 you
had ABC's John coral asking Obama's
White House press secretary Jay Carney
about this issue five years ago in 2014
it then came up again in 2016 but again
that the mainstream media and the left
didn't want to talk about it so they
didn't have to talk about it even two
months ago I was sitting in a fox
greenroom and I was talking to Dan bond
geno who has a great podcast and Dan
said watch out for this Ukraine thing if
Biden doesn't play his cards right this
is going to become a big campaign issue
even then this is just a few months ago
I still didn't know exactly what was
going on over there so Democrats are so
focused on impeaching Trump right now
that they're willing to burn down Biden
to do it why are they willing to burn
down Biden a few possible reasons one is
they don't have faith that Joe Biden is
the candidate who's going to beat Trump
fair enough if you looked at his
performances at the last Democratic
debates
think you would have much faith in Biden
either even if you were a Biden
supporter or a Democrat supporter so
with what one possibility is is they
look at by than they say there's no way
this guy's go in the distance
whatever let's impeach Trump it's gonna
take out Biden but then we'll deal with
Bernie or Elizabeth Warren or somebody
that's one option the other one is they
don't really care about beating Trump I
don't think Nancy Pelosi really wants to
beat Donald Trump why not
because now she's the minority her
shi'ite rather she's the Speaker of the
House but she doesn't have the Senate
and she doesn't have the White House so
she gets to grandstand she gets to be
the Speaker of the House she gets to
raise a lot of money she gets to now
especially try to keep her caucus in
line but she doesn't have to be
responsible for very much if you're in
the Democratic House leadership that is
a pretty good position to be in and one
of the reasons that they're trying to
impeach Trump right now I suspect is
that Nancy Pelosi is looking around at
AOC plus three and she's seeing a lot of
discontent in her party and she's saying
that maybe people don't don't like her
all that much and so she's willing to
impeach him if it means it's going to
help her keep control of the house
absolutely plausible but either way it's
a kamikaze mission and it gives
President Trump a major fundraising
advantage so we just got the q3 numbers
out in the third quarter
president Trump raised 125 million
dollars now we hear these numbers all
the time so sometimes it's difficult to
keep track of what you're supposed to
raise if you're an incumbent and this
quarter versus that quarter just to put
it in perspective when Barack Obama ran
for re-election in 2011 this was the
last time we had an incumbent who was
running for re-election he raised 70
million dollars in the third quarter and
he won that election don't forget he was
re-elected so he raised 70 million Trump
nearly doubled that in the third quarter
of 2019 125 million bucks how did he
raise all that money one of the key
reasons why he raised all that money
impeachment so after Nancy Pelosi goes
out there and
as we are going to open a formal
impeachment inquiry into President Trump
the Trump campaign didn't run hide Trump
campaign didn't cry they didn't they
they followed Rahm Emmanuel's advice
which has never let a good crisis go to
waste so they immediately started
sending out fundraising emails they
brought in 8.5 million dollars in just
two days that is a lot of scratch think
about that President Obama 2011 raises
70 million in the entire third quarter
Trump raises eight and a half million
two days because of impeachment because
people don't like this they don't like
being told that we have a presidential
election and then you elect the guy that
you want to elect and then immediately
you're told nope sorry that doesn't work
so we're gonna try to remove them for
collusion we're gonna try to remove them
for a porn star we're gonna try to
remove them for colluding with a
different government we're gonna they're
just gonna undo it people hate that and
it looks like it's it's backfiring this
backs up what I have been saying all
along impeachment is a huge win for
Trump he should be hoping for
impeachment let's not forget impeachment
helped the Clinton administration in the
90s now it helped Bill Clinton
personally it helped the Democrats in
the 90s pretty well because the American
people thought it was a bit of an
overstep maybe the Democrats are playing
the long game here because don't forget
in the 90s you've got all these
investigations into Clinton going back
to the first term then Newt Gingrich
wins and the Gingrich revolution
Republicans take the house in 1994 and
then there's more blowback against him
Newt Gingrich eventually resigns the
speaker Bill Clinton obviously is
reelected and but then in 2000 George W
Bush won the White House more or less
running against Bill Clinton and Bill
Clinton didn't play a huge role on the
campaign trail for Al Gore so maybe
Democrats are playing the long game here
this to me is one of the more plausible
theories which is for all their talk
they don't think they're gonna be Trump
in 2020 I don't think they're gonna be
Trump in 2020 I guess it's possible I
just don't think it's gonna happen so
for them they're gonna run really hard
against Trump they're gonna try to raise
some money galvanized some support and
play it for a longer game when they've
got better candidates cuz the candidates
they have right now are not
talented Joe Biden is well past his
prime if he ever had a prime Bernie
Sanders same thing Elizabeth Warren now
they're touting her as the great central
candidate she has a lot of flaws she has
a terrible voice she's panders to
everybody she's radically left-wing at
least for recent years and let's not
forget she pretended to be an Indian for
her entire career to her own
professional advantage liya Wafaa that
doesn't just go away we're not really
talking about it now Trump is not gonna
let up on that and it I think it does
really hurt her with a particularly
racial minority voters and you see this
reflected in her poll numbers so
President Trump right now is making a
killing on impeachment and you don't
need to just look at the the fundraising
numbers to see that we also have more
polls that are just spelling doom for
the Democrats this is a very very big
it's not even quite a poll it's an
election experiment that is coming out
of the New York Times so keep this in
mind here's the context Joe Biden's lead
is now down to just four point two
percent according to Real Clear Politics
don't forget this guy started he was the
leader of the pack double-digit leads
now according to real clear which looks
at all of the polls he stand 24.2% lead
by the time this podcast is actually
published who knows with what it's going
to be the new york times now is
reporting on a new election survey
experiment here's the experiment they
took just about 4,000 Americans 30 973
Americans and this was conducted by
Democratic data firm chievous analytics
and over one week they took half the
participants and they showed them news
articles about the Democrats leftward
shift so that was half the participants
and then the other half of the
participants saw new snippets of just
random information you know election
dates and that sort of stuff what they
were trying to measure is the effect of
news about the Democrats leftward shift
what that does to independent voters
these were all so-called independent
voters
the news that they showed them was news
about decriminalizing southern border
crossings it was news about expanding
illegal aliens right to welfare and
government services it was news about
how we're gonna get rid of our health
care system and replace it with a
government-run system it was news about
free school free college for for all
children for everybody these were all by
the way not these weren't just made up
it's not like they they wrote them like
a work of fiction
these were pulled from actual news
stories what was the result
independence became six full percentage
points less likely to vote for
Democratic candidates after reading the
news about the leftward shift and this
has been the Trump campaign strategy all
along which is appeal to moderates
appeal to independents appeal to normal
people who object to pretending to be an
Indian for thirty years of your career
and object to free health care for
illegal aliens and object to reparations
for slavery and object to a ninety three
trillion dollar green New Deal
environmental bill and just normal
people you know who the only sort of
people who could ever get behind those
kind of radical ideas are highly over
credentialed elites in the media and
politics normal Americans people between
the two coasts people who don't live in
politics all day long don't like that
sort of stuff and now we have an
experiment showing and this is a
democratic firm and this is coming from
the New York Times six full percentage
points less likely so what does that
mean we know the leftward lurch is
happening we've been seeing that happen
the whole time
we've been seeing the Democrats willing
to kill off their frontrunner kill off
Joe Biden and we've been seeing that
their cotton ánow to Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren the media want
Elizabeth Warren they really want her to
be the nominee
I will prove it to you that they're
going for a warrant and we will examine
what that means for 2020 but first I've
got to thank our friends over at Express
VPN oh how I love expressvpn you know
that you cannot trust certain elements
over there in Silicon Valley
name the companies but they are not
treating you fairly for your politics
they're not treating you fairly on
social media platforms how do you think
they're gonna handle your privacy and
your online data because when you go
online you were just giving people you
are dishing all of your information out
over to them this is why I highly
recommend using Express VPN every time
you go online every time big tech
companies can use your IP address to
match your internet activity to your
identity or location and let me tell you
something if you were listening to this
show something tells me you get up to
some pretty weird stuff on the internet
okay you go and you open up that little
incognito browser window okay and then
you type in those websites like daily
wire comm or whatever these are things
look these are things that obviously I
go to these websites to daily wire calm
leftist here's tumbler org sure I go to
those when that sort of stuff comes out
it can really have some bad effects for
your your professional reputation and
your livelihood so make sure that you
encrypt your data expressvpn has the
added benefit of encrypting 100% of your
data to keep you safe from people who
you don't want to have your data
expressvpn software takes just a minute
to set up on your computer or phone if
you tap one button you are protected so
if you're like me and you believe that
your internet data should belong to you
and on to those giant tech companies
that I don't like very much that aren't
especially friendly to conservatives
enough said check out expressvpn
seriously that is the answer protect
your online activity today with a VPN
that I trust to keep my data safe
expressvpn comm / michael mi CH AE l
claim an exclusive offer just for my
listeners expr ESS VPN dot-com / michael
mi CH AE l three months free with a
one-year package expressvpn comm slash
michael to get started do it today so we
know the left word lurch is happening we
know the media want Elizabeth Warren the
one way that you can tell who the media
want to be the Democratic nominee is how
they joke about that person so Saturday
Night Live they just put out a satire of
the Democratic debates
and the satire opens up and they make
fun of beta or work for being a nobody
that's the crux of the jokes against
beta or you overestimated how much we
like you you're a nobody you're kind of
doofy what you're not going anywhere
then it gets to cory booker and the joke
about cory booker is corey you got to go
home early and beat traffic you're never
going to be the president your numbers
are so low you go only get to say five
words on the stage then it gets to
Andrew yang the whole joke about Andrew
yang is he's so desperate he's gonna buy
votes which is true and he's not going
anywhere and he's not gonna be the
president then it gets to Marion
Williamson and the joke is that she's a
crazy kook fair enough then they get to
Elizabeth Warren listen to how they then
shift those are the only candidates they
talked about here they shift to talk
about Liz Warren okay you hear that
let's meet the actual candidates now
it's true
Andrew yang is not going to be President
Cory Booker is not going to be president
certainly Bay door works not going to be
President it is true that Liz Warren is
an actual candidate but part of this is
self-fulfilling if the media had talked
about how interesting Tulsi Gabbard is
Tulsi Gabbard would still be in the
debates if the media hadn't abandoned
beta or orc beta or work would still be
in the debates the media are not simply
covering the Democratic presidential
primaries the media are pushing the
candidates they like they tried to give
baito a big push then they preferred
some other candidates so it opens up
let's get to the actual candidates
Elizabeth Warren the other thing to note
here is a look who's playing was warren
kate mckinnon kate mckinnon is the SNL
cast member who played hillary clinton
last go-around Hillary Clinton being the
Democrats and the mainstream media's
preferred candidate in 2016 so they get
Kate McKinnon who looks a little bit
like Liz Warren but they're playing
blonde actresses they get Kate McKinnon
to play Warren and then not only do they
say let's get to the real candidates but
who's the first candidate they get to of
the real candidates Elizabeth Warren and
then they go in they're gonna here's the
joke
gonna make about about Liz Warren no
candidate is safe
yang is desperate and bado is doofy and
Corey's going nowhere and Marianne's a
kook okay what are they gonna say what's
the joke that they're gonna make about
Elizabeth Warren you guys enjoyed hot
girls summer cuz now it's School
Librarians
I have the energy of a mother of five
boys who all play a different sport
let's do it okay that's it then they
move on to another candidate so the joke
is she's not like a young hot girl or a
young hot candidate she's a mature
librarian so she is educated and mature
and serious ha ha ha that's a funny joke
and then the the only other joke in the
bit is she's got a lot of energy but you
know energy like a mom who has kids who
play different sports ha ha ha if they
were playing fair if the media actually
were going if a Saturday Night Live were
still a comedy show they would go after
and tell actual jokes about all of the
candidates but they can't do that I mean
it reminds me that you had these
comedians even from Saturday Night Live
who would say during the Obama years oh
it was so easy to make fun of George
Bush but you can't make fun of Barack
Obama
he's just there's nothing to joke about
there's a lot to joke about with Barack
Obama his voice his big ears his
absolutely hesitating halting manner of
speaking when he wasn't on teleprompter
his complete lack of accomplishment at
anything in his life other than running
for president his narcissism his total
self absorption there is a lot to his
his just constantly giving his America's
enemies whatever they want yeah there's
a lot to make fun of a brat Barack Obama
but they liked him so much they couldn't
do it so that's what's happening here
the media you were watching it in real
time they are falling in love with
Elizabeth Warren and why not she's one
of them she's got a lot of credentials
she worked at Harvard Law School
she's never drunk a beer in her life
other than that one time she tried to do
it on
she's part of the country-club
Chardonnay set from the Ivy League and
she's a total race hustler she is the
mainstream media okay she is these
people and so they can't joke about her
they can't do it they know that they
have to do something that sort of looks
like a joke about her so they make two
jokes first one is she's mature and
smart
the next joke is she has a lot of energy
that's not a joke okay
then they move on and they're
introducing the other candidate because
maybe you think okay they make the harsh
jokes about the cheap candidates but
then when you get to Warren Biden Bernie
Sanders they're going to go really easy
on all of them but they actually don't
so next they get up to Bernie Sanders
and they lay into him pretty good Bernie
Sanders
[Applause]
I'm so excited to be back and to ruin
things a second time that's actually a
pretty brutal joke which is and Larry
David obviously does a great Bernie
Sanders impression but the the joke is
Bernie Sanders you're the reason we lost
in 2016 hey Bernie
you know our audience all of whom wanted
to beat Trump you're the reason that
they weren't able to do that you gave
Trump the election which in some ways he
did he created a lot of discord within
the Democratic Party pretty good joke
that is what happened but it's pretty
brutal again compare this compare Liz
Warren is so smart and educated and has
so much energy haha - hey Bernie Sanders
you cost us the White House and made
Trump the president you've ruined
everything okay now they get to Joe
Biden what's the joke gonna be on Joe
Biden they're gonna go easy are they
gonna go hard what are the jokes about
the first one is he said he goes into
the dentist and asked for the high beams
so you're saying hey Joe you have
dentures you've got silly and ridiculous
looking dentures then the next joke is
really pretty cutting when you consider
that it's coming from the liberal New
York media class which is he's a man
right this is he's a man he's an
entitled man the first line he says is
all right America daddy's home daddy's
here father knows best I've got an
outdated patriarchal sense of myself I'm
entitled I'm a man I'm disregarding and
dismissing women I'm dismissing other
people who don't feel entitled then the
next joke is that he's a sexual assault
goes up and sniffs people's hair and
grabs him from behind
and then the final joke is he's senile
because he says every time I walk into a
room I say where am I who is this how'd
I get here that's a lot of jokes he's
got bad cosmetic surgery he's a sexist
he's entitled he's a rapist he's senile
they pecked five jokes in there compared
to one real joke against Bernie which is
that he ruined everything
compared to no actual jokes against Liz
Warren just sort of hidden compliments
she's smart
mature she's got a lot of energy the
media want Elizabeth Warren the media
have turned on Joe Biden
now one confounding factor in all this
and it's why they went a little bit you
know they only got that one joke in on
Bernie then they moved on Bernie is
still alive Bernie's still in the race I
actually should note even using that
phrase Bernie today had to cancel
campaign activities in the near future
because he does seem to be having
something of a serious health problem
he has a blocked artery they put a
couple stents in there
so he's hopefully gonna be recovering
fine he says he's doing fine
but all joking about the candidates
aside I do very much hope that Bernie
Sanders recovers mostly because I love
him being in the race I mean he is also
a child of God and you know I hope he he
does well for himself in his family but
also because he's really really funny to
have in the race and so I like him there
and I hope he he stays there that aside
the little health scare aside and from
all news reports it looks like he's
recovering well his campaign is still
doing quite well and the media have been
trying to take him at Politico ran a
piece just a few days ago about how his
campaign was going nowhere they had to
pick a lane they're not doing that well
well actually if you look at the third
quarter fundraising numbers he raised
twenty five million dollars obviously
it's 100 million dollars less than Trump
raised but if you're looking at a
crowded field of 10 or more Democratic
candidates 25 million is pretty good and
the better news for Bernie the 25
million is coming from 1.4 million
donors Bernie Sanders is the king of the
small dollar donation Bernie Sanders is
the king of getting regular old people
not those fat cats smoking their big
cigars but regular old people to donate
to his campaigns it looks like it's
happening again I was talking to a
political consultant friend of mine in
New York just a few days ago we were
saying what do you think it's gonna be
Warren is gonna be Biden and he said no
way it's gonna be Bernie said you've got
to be kidding me he goes Bernie's
first of all Bernie stands for something
second of all Bernie has a lot of energy
especially for a man his age and third
Bernie still has that small dollar
connection
he's got a lot of very enthusiastic
people behind him not like Trump but
pretty solid so you've got the
mainstream media coalescing around Liz
Warren you've got Liz Warren even she
even took the Working Families Party
endorsement from Bernie Sanders so the
Working Families Party is this kind of
just corrupt extra ballot line party
I've run against candidates who where
I'm working families in New York we've
we've worked for candidates who have
done that and it's it's a lot of shady
stuff but she goes in there and I assume
through some shady dealings takes the
endorsement from Bernie so that's not
great but a lot of Democrats still like
Bernie Sanders and this is where it's
gonna get really interesting it's
happening already today you're about to
see Bernie Sanders start holding Liz
Warren's feet to the progressive fire
it's been so nice thus far that Liz
Warren and Bernie haven't hit each other
none of the Democrats have really gone
after each other other than commonly
going after Biden and Tulsi Gabbard
going after Camilla and in a long run it
didn't work every well for either
Camelot or Tulsi Gabbard now you're
gonna start seeing them holding their
feet to the fire here is Bernie Sanders
leveling the first shot
just a little subtly he didn't call her
up by name basically saying that Liz
Warren needs to get real about her
progressive proposals because Warren has
stolen all of Bernie's proposals but she
hasn't stolen his honesty about taxes at
least Bernie tells you where we're gonna
have a lot knew of new services and
we're going to raise taxes on just about
everybody to pay for them
Liz Warren wants to promise all those
new welfare services but she doesn't
want to admit that people have to pay
for them and Bernie Sanders goes after
he says some people aren't being honest
with you but I am my question would be
around the current budget though I mean
why you're telling us you
taxes to do this why can't we adjust the
current budget for defense and pay for
us now as opposed to making us know this
futuristic thing we just and I'm not
saying we don't do it I think it's a
great idea we just have to turn it
around because raising taxes it's not
probably gonna apply for everyone well
we've got a hearing I'm happy to see
this is the issue this is why some
people don't talk about all right first
of all you're right in terms of we are
spending more than the next eight
nations combined in terms of defense
spending and I don't agree with that I
voted against all trust defense budgets
which are rising very rapidly you have a
system where Amazon made 10 billion of
Puppets Lesya did pay a nickel in
federal income taxes so there's a lot
that we have to do but I don't want to
like you all right if I told you
magically and you're gonna upgrade
health care it's not gonna cost you a
penny completely you hear that some
people aren't going to tell you
magically they're gonna raise all those
funds for the government some people
aren't being honest
Bernie's talking about Liz Liz Warren
here and it gets to the central Democrat
problem which is they are invariably it
seems running to the left whether it's
because Trump has just rolled them into
madness or whether it's because they're
finally just being honest about what
they believe they're running very far to
the left this fight between Bernie
Sanders and Liz Warren that is coming up
assuming Bernie gets better assuming the
campaign is still going on if if all of
that happens this fight coming up is
going to bring the party even further to
the left
they Bernie has the correct idea here
which is they have to raise taxes to pay
for their plans
he's gonna make Liz Warren be honest
about it and that's a really bad pitch
because we've just got a report that
Americans are now spending more on taxes
than they are on food clothing and
health care combined that's according to
the Bureau of Labor Statistics we'll get
into that we'll get into why more taxes
is a bad pitch and we'll get into how
best to go after Biden some
conservatives are suggesting an
investigation I think it's a bad idea
then why one
Obama appointed federal judge thinks
that Asians just have bad personality
isn't finally the dumbest article on the
internet today which takes on that great
problem that scourge in the United
States the ethnic food aisle at the
grocery store which the Washington Post
says is the last bastion of racism first
then we got a thing about Facebook in
YouTube you know I you've noticed
probably all week I've been coming to
you from very strange places around the
country now I am in Washington DC
because tonight I am going to be giving
the third speech in my fall young
America's Foundation tour which is
called men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths the uncomfortable
truth that I'm going to be talking about
tonight is that George Washington was a
pretty good guy it shows you where we
are as a culture in 2019 that now if you
go to George Washington University and
defend George Washington you are giving
a controversial speech but that's where
we are it should be a lot of fun that's
gonna be seven o'clock at GW and we are
going to stream it so check it out on
The Daily wire YouTube page and young
America's Foundation we'll be tweeting
that out too so that's gonna be a lot of
fun go to daily wire.com ten bucks a
month one hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the Matt Walsh show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag that's
coming up tomorrow so be sure to get
them in you get another Kingdom another
Kingdom is going to be released this
week for subscribers only though if
you're not a subscriber you got to wait
until Monday so I'm telling you guys
it's the best season yet go out there
and get it and you need that left just
tears tumblr especially when I defend
George Washington at GW tonight the
tears are going to be flowing that it's
going to be going over the Potomac the
Potomac is going to flood as if global
warming were really a threat to our
civilization so go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
so Democrats are now billing eventually
going to be running on we are gonna
raise your taxes yes we are going to
raise your taxes the more honest voices
on the left are already saying this
they're going to force the more
dishonest ones to say it too but this
comes as a new survey from the Bureau of
Labor Statistics shows Americans are way
way way over taxed so Americans on
average or spending more on taxes than
they are on food clothing and health
care combined you can even see the
numbers American consumer units spent on
average nine thousand thirty one dollars
and ninety three cents on federal income
taxes they spent a little over five
thousand dollars on Social Security
taxes almost twenty three hundred
dollars on state and local income taxes
twenty two hundred dollars on property
taxes and seventy eight dollars on other
taxes is no tax you coming and going
that's what the taxman does this brings
for the average American 18,617 dollars
and ninety three cents total in taxes
now the average American consumer unit
while they were paying these taxes they
were also spending nearly eight thousand
dollars on food nearly five thousand
dollars on health care eighteen hundred
sixty six dollars on apparel and
services that brings it to fourteen
thousand seven hundred fifty eight
dollars and eleven cents total almost
four thousand dollars more on taxes than
on food clothing and health care it's
too much that's too much you know the
left and kind of the new right new
conservatives and the center they would
always mock the conservative movement in
the 60s and 70s and 80s and 90s for just
all they cared about was low taxes and
people don't get all that excited about
low taxes and it's a little too Lankesh
and rationalists low taxes is about so
much more than just taxes taxes
represent your labor taxes represent
your time taxes represents your freedom
of choice taxes represents your control
over your own life in your own destiny
money is a symbol
okay money that's a dollar or the dollar
bill isn't intrinsically worth something
it's worth something because of what it
says about the economy about the country
about your time about your work if
people are spending so much more on
their taxes than they are on basic
necessities that's not a great sign I
mean you could be taxed 40 percent I
friends were taxed at the 50 percent
effectively and that's not even taking
into account sales taxes and all the
other little taxes that that people get
you on that's too much that's way way
too much God takes ten percent the mob
takes ten percent there is no reason for
the government to be taking forty or
fifty percent of your money home so how
should Trump play all of this he should
watch it happen and he should laugh you
know there was a suggestion from Peter
Schweitzer who's very good but yeah he
runs the Government Accountability
Institute I think it's called and he
just looks into corruption at the
government level and he writes excellent
books he has this suggestion right now
that Trump needs to get really involved
in all of this that that Trump actually
should I guess through the Senate
Republicans use the subpoena power to
investigate Joe and hunter Biden to get
really active in in areas of this
campaign I think it's a bad idea I think
if you get the White House to really get
aggressive here or if you get the Senate
to start subpoenaing different people
and and really heavily investigating Joe
and Hunter Biden it creates a sort of
moral equivalence between the house and
the Senate the House Democrats in the
Senate Republicans so right now the
house is impeaching Trump it looks
ridiculous he raised half eight and a
half million dollars off of it and
really more later on why would we want
to look ridiculous to because already
the Biden campaign is falling apart I
mean you're seeing it happening in the
polling numbers you're seeing it
happening in how the media is is
treating Joe Biden if we get involved
the only advantage I could see to that
is if we get involved the Democrats will
defend Joe Biden
and then if the Democrats defend Joe
Biden has a better chance of getting the
nomination and look maybe that is the
long game maybe people think Joe Biden
is the weakest candidate to run against
in 2020 I'm not totally convinced of
that I can see an argument for it but
that is a really convoluted complicated
long game I think right now things are
going very very well for conservatives
things are going very very poorly for
Democrats and they can't figure out
right now how to fix it they can't
figure out how to write the ship they
just can't can't win for losing
everything they're doing is wrong I
wouldn't interfere with that I would let
that continue to happen I it would spell
good news for conservatives in 2020
really bad news and without really much
good luck in sight I think for the
Democrats now moving on from 2020
looking at just the culture broadly this
is there's one case that we have been
talking about for months and months now
it's this case brought by Asian students
and Asian parents who had kids apply to
Harvard and they were rejected or there
were students at Harvard but they they
found this problem in the admissions
policy which is that Harvard is
systematically discriminating against
Asian applicants on the basis of race
now how do they do it cuz you're not
allowed to do that right I mean you are
there's affirmative action which is race
discrimination codified into law so you
already are a little bit but even so
Asian applicants were still being
underrepresented how did they do it the
way they did it was Harvard gives
students different scores so you got the
SAT score right and you just take the
test and you report your SAT score
unless your mother's Aunt Becky in which
case your cheat on the test and get into
college you get the SAT score you've got
your GPA kind of hard to cheat your GPA
you've got your extracurriculars you've
got all these boxes right that are
pretty hard if you're in the admissions
office to cheat and then you have at
Harvard the personality score so the
personality score measures likability
helpfulness courage kindness positive
personality people like to
be around you that's one category this
person is widely respected that's
another category obviously very
subjective highly vulnerable to abuse
what this survey showed of the Asian
applicants is that Asians had the
highest scores in academic and
extracurricular rankings but they had by
far the lowest personality rankings so
how can you explain this there are two
explanations that's it either you
believe that Asians just have absolutely
terrible personalities across the board
or you realize that the personality
score is just a way to discriminate
against Asians on the basis of race
because these universities have done
this for so long which is they don't
want too many Asians or they don't want
too many Jews or they're one whatever
race they don't want their and so they
find a way to keep that number
suppressed this lawsuit brought that
showed that statistical experts looking
at the applications so up an Asian
American male applicant had a 25% chance
of admission or if he had a 25% chance
of admission he would have a 32% chance
of admission if he were white he would
have a 77% chance of admission if he
were Hispanic he would have a 95% chance
of admission if he were black that's if
he's beginning with all of his other
scores starting at 25% he would get a
huge advantage if he were a different
race and he was being disadvantaged
because of his own race so anyway this
federal judge today this Obama appointee
Allison burrows says that Harvard can
keep discriminating and her reasoning
was this is a direct quote
Harvard's witnesses credibly testified
that they did not use race in assigning
personal ratings and did not observe any
improper discrimination in the
admissions process so so what she's
saying is she found out that Harvard she
discovered she concluded Harvard is not
discriminating against Asians on the
basis of race because Harvard told her
that they're not discriminating against
Asians on the basis of race and you know
why would Harvard lie about something
like that I mean you
you're not calling them liers are you so
anyway no big deal I guess Asians just
have bad personalities is what this
Obama appointed judge is saying this is
first of all it shows you how bizarre
and incoherent racial politics can be I
mean it's not as though broadly as a
demographic group Asian immigrants and
second generation Asians are so
incredibly well off in America I'm from
New York a lot of Asian immigrants and
children of Asian immigrants have
nothing they came here with nothing
their parents work constantly the kids
work extremely hard in school and then
they go to some either magnet school or
charter school or Stuyvesant High School
and then they work their way in and try
to get into college and they are being
discriminated against and there's no
other way to put it it's on the basis of
race and somehow in leftist woke culture
this is a good thing because I guess I
don't know I guess the left just prefers
certain races to other races so they
would rather give a a systemic advantage
to black and Hispanic applicants and
they and they were willing to pay the
price of disadvantaging Asian applicants
the other thing this shows you is the
importance of the judges the judges
matter this whole this judge was
appointed by Obama in 2014 okay 2014
five years later she's making these big
decisions now this is gonna be appealed
certainly it's gonna go up to the
Supreme Court hopefully those
conservatives on the court don't go
squishy because it's a huge miscarriage
of justice what's happening in Harvard
and somebody should stand up for it even
if everyone else has gone crazy with
race and they have gone crazy with race
this from the Washington Post I just
have to get to it before we go the
dumbest article on the Internet today
the article is to David Chang he is a
food expert or something the ethnic food
aisle is racist others say it's
convenient of course right off the bat
obviously a slow news day the ethnic
food aisle this is a food I didn't even
know this exists but I guess there's an
aisle in certain growth I don't do my
own grocery shopping also because sweet
little Lisa is just a good wife and I
would die and starve if if I were not
married to her but I guess there's an
ethnic food aisle and this is how the
piece begins to millions of shoppers the
supermarket is just a place to stock up
on produce and pantry staples to keep
the family fed
but to others especially children of
immigrants who may already feel pushed
to the margins of the American
mainstream the supermarket can be just
another place to experience the sting of
outsider status quit ball here we go
children of immigrants who are listening
to this show right now please write in
on Twitter do supermarkets make you feel
quote the sting of outsider status just
let me know I'll put a bowl up on
Twitter something the piece goes on the
sting occurs whenever they walk down the
ethnic food aisle the section of the
supermarket that to some plays out like
a remnant of the Jim Crow era so
according to the Washington Post there's
an aisle at the supermarket where you
can buy certain Asian spices and oyster
sauce and that's the same as lynchings
it's now my words they're the ones who
brought up the Jim Crow era and they say
it reminds them of times when laws
established separate facilities for
african-americans in the
post-reconstruction south what this is
how this comes across quote to the
shoppers they seemingly target as de
facto segregation another kind of
separate but equal policy that
marginalized African Americans for
generations because supermarkets are
stocking up on very niche food products
that generally speaking a small number
of people like okay does walking down a
separate aisle for yum yum sauce and
adobo make you feel like you are being
reserved and refused rather service at
the Woolworth lunch counter does it I
don't think so and then they give you
their thesis if you go to the ethnic
food aisle that is sort of the last
bastion of racism that you can see in
full daylight in retail America David
Chang that's what he says it's something
that's got to go so I just want to point
out I am willing to accept the premise
ok I'm willing to accept that ethnic
food aisles are racist and whatever if
if we admit that it's the last bastion
of racism and we get rid of ethnic food
aisles then the left has to agree to
stop yapping about
racism because you said you just said
it's the last bastion of racism I don't
think it's a bastion of racism but you
think it you think it's the last bastion
and you're always trying to divide
people based on race and identity
politics so okay
I get right last bastion let's pass a
law we get rid of the ethnic food aisle
then that's it no more race hustling no
more identity politics deal something
tells me that I'm gonna take that deal
he complains he goes on he complains
that olive oil is in the main food
aisles but but you know yum-yum sauce is
in its own separate aisle first of all
everyone uses olive oil people don't use
oyster sauce and rice vinegar that much
but also that's not some vile bigotry
because the products are available you
get to just go to the aisle and buy them
and then he contradicts himself he goes
on he says the ongoing segregation of
these foods isn't about acceptance among
the mainstream Asian and Latino cuisines
have long been embraced by Americans of
every stripe and you can sometimes even
see this play out in supermarkets
instant ramen and tortilla soups may sit
right next to boxes of chicken noodle
and cream of chicken soups those
standards of mid-century America so he
actually admits that some of the foods
are in the regular aisle the ones that
are more mainstream because people eat
instant ramen noodles because people are
poor college students sometimes but they
don't always go eat yum yum sauce then
he complains that very very niche
specialty products like coconut milk and
stir-fry sauces and curry paste are in
the separate aisle few things it shows
us three things mainstream media are so
incredibly separated from mainstream
America they don't realize how different
their tastes are than the vast majority
of this country second thing is this
grievance carries social currency it
there is an aisle the foods are there
they're even especially easy to find the
third thing it shows you is you're
damned if you do and you're damned if
you don't with the left and with
identity politics this is like the color
blind versus the color conscious society
when ethnic and racial differences are
highlighted that is called bigoted
because you're separating people based
on race and ethnicity when ethnic and
racial differences are ignored
that's called erasure that's called
appropriation that's called another form
of bigotry you can't
with them because all they want to do is
complain that's the left for you that's
just what they do I also don't think
that this is really being pushed by
people who are actually terribly
offended by this I think generally
speaking this is pushed by white
liberals like for instance the people
who tend to publish and read The
Washington Post
that's gonna be the topic of my speech
tonight as I defend George Washington
from mostly white liberals who want to
destroy him so head on over to George
Washington if you're in town otherwise
catch it on the live stream and I'll see
you in any case tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
they'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there